so we mentioned uh some of the dangers
of uh some of the concerns about large
language models that said uh you know
there's been a long-running fear of
these embodied
robots uh why do you think people are
afraid of uh like the robots yeah I
wanted to show you this this
so this this is a Wall Street Journal
and this is all about chat GPT right but
look at the picture yeah it's a humanoid
robot that's saying I will say that
looks scary and it says I'm going to
replace you yeah and so the humanoid
robot is sort of is the embodiment of
this chat GPT tool that there's reason
to be a little bit nervous about how it
gets deployed yeah so I'm nervous about
that connection
um
it's unfortunate that they chose to use
a robot as that embodiment for as you
and I just said there's big differences
in in this
but people are afraid because we've been
taught to be afraid for over a hundred
years so you know the word robot was
developed by a playwright named Carol
chapek in 1921 to check a playwright for
Awesome's Universal robots and in that
first depiction of a robot the robots
took over
the end of the story
and you know people love to be afraid
and so we've been entertained by these
stories for a hundred years
but I
and I think that's as much why people
are afraid as anything else as we've
been
sort of taught that this is the logical
progression through fiction
um
I think it's fiction
I think uh what people more and more
will realize just like you said
that the threat like say you have a
super intelligent AI embodied in a robot
that's much less threatening because
it's visible it's verifiable it's right
there in physical reality and we humans
know how to deal with physical reality I
think it's much scarier when you have
arbitrary scaling of intelligent AI
systems in the digital space
that they could uh pretend to be human
so robot spot is not going to be pretend
it could pretend it's human all at once
you can tell you you could put Chad GPD
on top of it but you're gonna know it's
not human because you have a contact
with physical reality and you're going
to know whether or not it's doing what
you asked it to do yeah like it's not
gonna like if it like I mean I'm sure
you can start just like a dog uh lies to
you is like I didn't I wasn't part of
tearing up that couch
Spock and try to lie that like you know
it wasn't me that spilled that thing but
it's you're going to kind of figure it
out eventually it's if it happens
multiple times you know
uh but I think that Humanity has figured
out how to make machines safe yeah and
there's you know there's regulatory
environments and certification uh
protocols that we've developed in order
to figure out how to make machines safe
we don't know we and don't have that
experience with software
that can be propagated worldwide in an
instant
and so I think we needed to develop
those protocols and those tools and so
uh
that's work to be done but I don't think
the fear of that and that work should
necessarily impede our ability to not
get robots out because again I think I
think we can judge when a robot's being
safe so and again just like in that
image there's a fear that robots will
take our jobs I just um I took a ride I
was in San Francisco I know way more
Vehicles than autonomous vehicle and uh
I've done it several times they're
they're doing credible work over there
uh but
uh people flicked it off the car so I
mean that's a long story of what the
psychology of that is it could be maybe
big Tech or what I I don't know exactly
what they're flicking off yeah but there
is an element of like these robots are
taking our jobs or or
irreversibly transforming Society such
that it will have economic impact and
the little guy will be uh would lose a
lot would lose their well-being is there
something to be said about
um
the fear that robots will take our jobs
you know at every
um significant technological
transformation uh there's been fear of
you know an automation anxiety yes that
uh it's it's going to have a broader
impact than than we expected
and there there will be uh
you know jobs will change
um sometime in the future we're going to
look back at people who manually
unloaded these boxes from trailers and
we're going to say why did we ever do
that manually but there's a lot of
people who are doing that job today
that it could be impacted
um but I think the reality is as I said
before we're going to build the
Technologies those very same people can
operate it and so I think there's a
pathway to upskilling and operating just
like look we used to farm with hand
tools and now we farm with machines and
nobody has really regretted that
transformation
and I think the same can be said for a
lot of manual labor that we're doing
today
and on top of that you know look we're
we're entering a new world where where
demographics are going to have a strong
impact on economic growth
and the you know the advanced uh the
first world is losing population quickly
um in Europe
they're worried about hiring enough
people just to keep the logistics supply
chain going
and you know part of this is the
response to covid and everybody's sort
of thinking back
what they really want to do with their
life but these jobs are getting harder
and harder to fill and I just I'm
hearing that over and over again
so I think frankly this is the right
technology at the right time
um where we're going to need some of
this work to be done and we're going to
want tools to enhance that productivity
and the scary impact I think again uh
gbt comes to the rescue in terms of
being much more terrifying
um
the scary scary impact of basically so I
I'm a I guess a software person inside a
program a lot and the fact that people
like me could be easily replaced
uh by gbt
that's going to have a
well a lot you know anyone who deals
with texts and writing a draft proposal
might be easily done with uh chat GPT
now Consultants
journalists yeah
um everybody is sweating but on the
other hand you also want it to be right
and they don't know how to make it right
yet it but it might make a good starting
point for you to iterate boy do I have
to talk to you about modern journalism
that's another conversation altogether
but yes uh more right than the average
uh
um the the mean journalist yes
um
you spearheaded the NT weaponization
letter
uh Boston Dynamics has can you
describe uh what that letter States and
the general topic of the use of robots
in war
we
authored a letter and then got several
leading robotics companies around the
world including you know unitary and
China and
agility here in the United States and
um animal and in Europe
and you know some others to co-sign a
letter that said we won't put weapons on
our robots
and part of the motivation there is you
know as these robots start to become
commercially available you can see
videos online of people who've gotten a
robot and strapped a gun on it and shown
that they can you know operate the gun
remotely while driving the robot around
and so having a robot that has this
level of Mobility
and that can easily be configured in a
way that could harm somebody from a
remote operators
justifiably a scary thing
and so we felt like it was important to
draw a bright line there and say we're
not going to allow this
for
um
you know reasons that we think
ultimately it's better for the whole
industry if if it grows in a way where
uh the robots are ultimately going to
help us all and make our lives more
fulfilled and productive but by goodness
you're going to have to trust the
technology to let it in and if
and if you think the robot's going to
harm you that's gonna that's gonna hurt
impede the growth of that industry
so we thought it was important to to
draw a bright line
and uh and then publicize that and and
our plan is to you know begin to engage
with
lawmakers and Regulators let's figure
out what the rules are going to be
around the use of this technology
um and use our position as leaders in
this industry and Technology
to help force that issue
and so we are in fact I have a I have a
policy you know director at my company
whose job it is to engage with the
public to enjoy engage with interested
parties and including Regulators to sort
of begin these discussions
he has a really important topic and it's
an important topic for people that worry
about the impact of robots on our
society with autonomous weapon systems
so I'm glad you're sort of leading the
way in this